[Aplausos]
[Música]
venezuela es como juego de tronos todos
queremos saber qué va a pasar pero a la
vez todos sabemos que vamos a terminar
decepcionados con el final y
precisamente de eso es de lo que vamos a
hablar hoy muchos nos habéis hecho la
misma pregunta la gran duda que todo el
mundo tiene sobre este país
[Música]
qué puede pasar en venezuela es decir
hablamos de uno de los mayores desastres
económicos y humanitarios de la historia
moderna en sólo 10 años han pasado de
exportar petróleo a exportar refugiados
pero todo eso ya lo sabéis y si no lo
sabéis tenemos toda una playlist en
visual polític dedicada a este país por
supuesto venezuela no es el único país
que ha pasado por semejante debacle
económica por ejemplo hace poco
hablábamos de mi cara
[Música]
durante los años 80 nicaragua también
sufría de hiperinflación escasez y
pobreza extrema sin embargo en este caso
había una alternativa de gobierno clara
y era fácil imaginar los posibles
escenarios que se podrían dar el caso de
venezuela es una auténtica incógnita
pensando bien el gobierno de maduro está
contra las cuerdas prueba de ello fue el
lanzamiento del petró una cripto moneda
de la que ya os hemos hablado aquí en
visual político con la que venezuela
intenta desesperadamente ganar algo de
divisa extranjera al paso que van
nicolás maduro ni siquiera va a poder
pagar al ejército que le defiende
[Música]
pero ese no es el mayor problema el
auténtico misterio sobre el venezuela es
cuál es la alternativa de verdad existe
alguien capaz de sustituir al gobierno
de maduro en resumen que es
prácticamente imposible entender la
situación actual de venezuela y
precisamente por eso nos hemos ido a
preguntar a todo un experto en
transiciones políticas y os preguntaréis
os hemos traído a un historiador a un
economista nada de eso iván pillud fue
nada más y nada menos que el ministro de
finanzas en uno de los primeros
gobiernos democráticos de la república
checa
[Música]
hablamos de uno de los responsables
directos de que chequia sea el país que
es hoy en día pero aquí no termina la
historia después de tener una carrera
política digna de película
iván philip empezó una trayectoria
empresarial ya que no adivináis donde
pues exactamente en latinoamérica es
decir que conoce esta región como la
palma de su mano y hoy está aquí con
todos nosotros os presento a iván
peeling hola fonseca y un abrazo muy
fuerte a todos los suscriptores de
visual político efectivamente es
imposible imaginar lo que puede pasar en
venezuela
pero hoy vamos a dibujar tres escenarios
posibles para este país así que la
pregunta de hoy es y puede pasar en
venezuela y posibles escenarios nos
podemos encontrar hoy vamos a contestar
a estas preguntas pero antes antes vamos
a hacer un pequeño paréntesis
porque si ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
algunos mis queridos amigos chavistas
son más turistas que sé que muchos
estaréis viendo este vídeo antes de que
os lancéis a escribir en los comentarios
que en visual político sólo se habla de
venezuela os sugiero que echéis un
vistazo a todos los demás vídeos del
canal y veréis que hemos dedicado
muchísimo más tiempo a otros países como
arabia saudita colombia o méxico en
resumen que en visual político cubrimos
todo el mundo y creo que nadie puede
tachar nos de dogmáticos hecha esta
aclaración vamos a ver un poco de
historia
[Música]
la salida checa quedaos con este nombre
patlán hubble pocas personas han tenido
tanta influencia como este hombre en su
país básicamente la república checa que
conocemos hoy en día la república checa
en la que yo vivo es lo que es gracias a
baja
[Música]
es todo un modelo de transición
democrática mientras otros países como
rusia todavía son pobres y
extremadamente desiguales república
checa- es una sociedad próspera moderna
y sobre todo extremadamente igualitaria
de hecho las diferencias entre ricos y
pobres en este país son muchísimo más
suaves incluso que en suecia o noruega
pero y como llegaron a este punto
[Música]
pero esto no siempre fue así hasta el
año 1989
los checos teníamos un gobierno títere
de moscú bajo la dictadura de gustav usa
cosas tan normales como irse de
vacaciones a otro país estaban
prohibidas o muy difíciles si querías
alquilar una casa necesitabas un permiso
del gobierno que podría tardar hasta
años en ella
otros países como polonia también
estaban bajo dominio soviético pero
tenían los regímenes algo más abiertos
de hecho muchos checos cruzaban la
frontera con polonia para poder
conseguir libros que estaban prohibidos
en su puesto aquí sin embargo todo
cambió a finales de los años 80 aunque
nunca llegamos a tener la intención de
venezuela sigue sufrimos escasez de
productos querías comprar un coche
tenías que esperar
hasta que la fábrica te lo mandaba
incluso algo tan básicos como plátanos o
las bananas era un auténtico lujo que no
se encontraba prácticamente ninguna
tienda o solamente antes de navidad'
a eso le tenemos que sumar el hecho de
que la unión soviética ya no podía
seguir mandando dinero a sus aliados así
que sin apoyos extranjeros y con una
economía en bancarrota es normal que
surjan protestas de todo tipo por
supuesto que la policía reprimió con
violencia a las primeras manifestaciones
contra el gobierno de justa pero qué
pasa cuando de repente se juntan más de
250.000 personas en las calles de praga
[Música]
habría que estar loco para disparar a
cuarto de millón de personas
a diferencia de nicolás maduró el
gobierno checoslovaco supo entender que
lo más prudente era dejar el poder de
forma pacífica gracias a eso nuestro
amigo gustav husák pudo marcharse a un
retiro dorado y a esta revolución se la
pudo llamar la revolución de terciopelo
porque pues porque no hubo ningún
derramamiento de sangre sin embargo y
como os decía al principio la clave de
este proceso fue vaclav hável se trataba
de un escritor relativamente conocido
que capitalizó todo el descontento
popular
[Música]
la verdad y el amor deben imponerse
sobre la mentira y el odio
vaclav hável gravedad baza saber no era
tan conocido antes de la revolución de
terciopelo pero tenía todos los
elementos para ser un gran líder y la
pregunta que os estaréis haciendo ahora
mismo es existe un barça favela en
venezuela tal vez alguien desconocido
hasta ahora pero que en algún momento
pueda aparecer lo cierto es que no lo
sabemos y por eso vamos a imaginar un
escenario un poquito más pesimista
[Música]
la salida rumana qué pasa cuando un
dictador no abandona el poder a tiempo
pues ya os lo digo desde aquí nada bueno
os lo hemos explicado muchísimas veces
en visual político liderar un gobierno
autoritario puede ser una profesión de
alto riesgo y nicolás ceausescu es la
mejor prueba de ello se trata de uno de
los dictadores más brutales que hemos
tenido en euro
[Música]
a diferencia de nicolás maduró ceausescu
ni siquiera se esforzaba en preparar
elecciones a mañanas directamente era un
sistema basado en el culto a su persona
pero cuando la economía va mal
ni siquiera el líder más autoritario de
europa es capaz de mantener el tipo al
igual que en el resto de países
postsoviéticos a finales de los años 80
rumanía estaba prácticamente arruinado
en algunas regiones llegaron a verse
casos de malnutrición
[Música]
el 25 de diciembre del año 1989 después
de dar un discurso multitudinario los
ciudadanos pasaron de los aplausos a los
abucheos en cuestión de segundos
[Aplausos]
guarde el kim jong-un rumano era
ejecutado por sus opositores sin embargo
en este caso no fue una revolución en
contra del régimen ni siquiera lo
mataron los grupos anti comunistas
ceausescu murió a manos de sus propios
compañeros del partido fue un caso de
golpe de estado interno una facción más
moderada del partido comunista lugar se
hizo con las riendas del gobierno rumano
en el caso de venezuela podría ser una
facción del propio gobierno o del
ejército por supuesto no tendría que
terminar con la ejecución de nadie
simplemente hablaríamos de que nicolás
maduro se vería obligado a abandonar el
poder y marcharse a su casa oa una
mansión de lujo en cualquier país que le
acepte y al igual que ocurrió en rumanía
hablaríamos de un cambio totalmente
cosmético caras muy parecidas en el
gobierno pero unas políticas un poquito
más moderadas está claro que la rumanía
de hoy
no es un ejemplo de nada pero al menos
es un país estable con cierto movimiento
y crecimiento económico y donde al menos
ya no hay pobreza extrema
[Música]
y antes de continuar quiero hacer un
paréntesis y aquí sí que voy a ser
tajante en ningún momento estamos
deseándole el mal ni a nicolás maduro ni
a ninguno de los miembros de su gobierno
nos estamos limitando a analizar la
situación actual de venezuela
comparándola con precedentes históricos
absolutamente nada más no estamos
diciendo ni que este escenario fuera el
más deseable ni muchísimo menos que sea
nuestra recomendación o que sea lo que
nosotros deseamos ha quedado claro vale
ahora si queréis podemos continuar hasta
el momento no se sabe de ninguna facción
interna dentro del gobierno de maduro
que quiera derrocarle y por eso nos
queda todavía un último escenario un
escenario digno de película pero mal
visto lo visto todo es posible en
venezuela
un país en venta la salida china
recordáis que os decía que china es el
único aliado que le queda a venezuela lo
cierto es que china le ha prestado más
de 60 mil millones de dólares al
gobierno de nicolás maduro
muchos de estos préstamos son lo que
podríamos llamar petro créditos es decir
china le da un dinero a venezuela y
venezuela en lugar de devolverle divisa
contante y sonante lo devuelve en una
cantidad equivalente en petróleo tiene
sentido verdad si hay algo que le sobra
a venezuela es el humo de dinosaurio ya
sabéis que es el país con las mayores
reservas de crudo del mundo así que en
principio suena como un buen trato para
maduro verdad
[Música]
y cuál es el problema os preguntaréis
pues que como también sabéis la empresa
estatal que se encarga de extraer el
zumo de dinosaurio venezolano pedevesa
es un auténtico caos el barril de crudo
venezolano es el más caro de extraer del
mundo mucho más que el canadiense o el
noruego y eso explica qué pedevesa sea
incapaz de extraer su propio petróleo
para que os hagáis una idea la
producción de esta empresa a duras penas
llega al 43 por ciento de su capacidad y
cada vez va a menos muchos inversores
chinos ya están perdiendo la paciencia
pensad que no sólo estamos hablando del
gobierno desde jinping sino también de
muchas empresas privadas que habían
comprado bonos del estado venezolano o
que tenían inversiones en el sector del
petróleo y eso explica noticias como
esta
una empresa china sinopec demanda a
venezuela como muestra de unas
relaciones que se está deshilachando
pero la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es qué podría pasar si venezuela no
pudiera devolver las deudas que tiene
contraídas con el gobierno de china
[Música]
no olvidéis que tanto el ejército como
la policía de nicolás maduró está armada
con el dinero que llega de china es
decir que china podría paralizar el
gobierno de maduro en cualquier momento
eso significa que tienen poder
suficiente como para incautar muchas de
las propiedades que pedevesa tiene en
territorio venezolano
es decir que hablamos de la auténtica
joya de la corona pero de cuánto dinero
estaríamos hablando pues bien a día de
hoy los activos de pedevesa tienen un
valor de 231 mil millones de dólares y
venezuela le debe a siguen pin más de 60
mil millones de dólares
[Música]
en otras palabras que beijing podría
quedarse con la cuarta parte de las
propiedades de la empresa más grande de
venezuela prácticamente la única para
que os hagáis una idea el zumo de
dinosaurio supone el 97 por ciento de
las exportaciones de venezuela en otras
palabras que quedarse con pedevesa es
prácticamente un sinónimo de quedarse
con todo venezuela esta nueva dirección
de prevé se podría hacer los ajustes
necesarios para que la empresa pueda
werder a funcionar en principio esto
sería una buena noticia para la economía
venezolana que volvería a producir algo
que poder exportar
e
[Música]
pero batería de pies y manos al gobierno
nicolás maduro en otras palabras se dio
como vender todo un país los inversores
chinos y os preguntaréis es esto posible
hay algún signo que nos lleve a pensar
que esto va a ser una realidad pues
fijaos en esta noticia publicada hace
unas pocas semanas en xinhua news
xinhua news como ya os habréis imaginado
por el nombre es un portal de noticias
chino completamente adeptos al régimen
de xi jinping atentos a la noticia
[Música]
maduro crea la primera zona económica
especial basada en el petró si lleváis
tiempo suscritos a visual política ya
sabéis que eso de las zonas económicas
especiales es algo así como la marca de
la bestia cada vez que china decide
hacer negocios importantes en un país en
crecimiento lo primero que vemos es que
crea una zona económica especial un
espacio que tiene unas leyes especiales
basadas en la legislación china con
impuestos bajos y facilidades para
montar empresas pero en este caso
podrían ir un paso más allá no sólo
hablamos de invertir en un país o de
hacer negocios
hablamos de comprar la espina dorsal de
la revolución bolivariana maduro sin
pedevesa es como un rapero sin quincalla
así que si controlas toda la economía de
un país incluido el modo en el que se
financia un gobierno no podríamos decir
que has comprado el país entero
[Música]
pues algo así podría terminar pasando en
venezuela ya os digo que es una teoría
totalmente insólita nunca se ha visto
nada parecido en la historia pero como
hemos dicho ya todo es posible en este
país y ahora turno para ti cuál de estos
tres escenarios te parece más plausible
y repito plausible no deseable o tal vez
crees que veremos una mezcla de los tres
poderes dejarme la respuesta en los
comentarios y por mi parte ha sido un
placer estar un ratito con vosotros si
queréis podemos seguir en contacto a
través de twitter me encontraréis en
arroba iván para baja ira y como siempre
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribiros al
canal clicar en la campanita y así nos
perderéis ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones les ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]